we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to [ __ ] boots
you are down to your last life
you need to retire
oh brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommate well
I'm supposed to be a Fearless hero a
legend right this is a person party
that's your party so this is where
dignity Goes To Die the year start
coming and they don't stop coming
your Puss in Boots let's talk
you're funny uh what's your story my
story
[Applause]
what are we looking at cats have nine
lives watch watch watch watch
I think you should be having too high
now I am on my last life oh no
legendary
wish waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great pools in
Boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish to get me my
life's back okay okay pause on face I
won't make you back but first
hey slow down I know what I'm doing
what what what's funny nothing should be
funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
[Music]
you will find your reward does not come
easily Puss in Boots Goldie bears
[Music]
despair I am nothing when you only have
one life that's what makes it special go
get him tiger hey take it easy
[Music]
it's gonna be fun
[Music]
[Applause]
in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out